yeah and uh look josh allen is clearly
going to be the guy for years and years
to come and that's one of the other
topics that came up last week brandon
being the gm of the bills
talking about the josh allen second
contract he's now in the window
where it could be paid to him at any
time here's being on that subject
he said he was going to give us a nice
hometown discount
and you know hopefully we'll get him
done no uh in all seriousness
you know we'll talk to josh and his
people uh probably later in the spring
get through the draft where we can just
focus on that that's obviously
uh a big financial commitment that you
have to make and so
um that'll probably be you know sometime
made through the summer
you know i don't know and that's not
uncommon that's a timeline where things
like that tend to happen patrick mahomes
last year it was june i think when he
did his deal right
bottom line is it's not going to get any
cheaper as time goes by what you have to
ask yourself though
do you know enough have you seen enough
do you believe enough in what you have
so you don't get yourself into a jared
goff situation
or if you wait for more information it
is gonna cost you
more money that's the reality it's
always going to go
up the market goes up the price goes up
dak prescott set the new bar that deal
so much better than the one that patrick
mahomes signed
and uh the the the reality is
if you swoop in now yeah and you make
him an offer he can't refuse
that's right and he still has two years
left of commitment and he knows how he
plays the game and there is
injury risk and he wants to stay in
buffalo
the sooner they get on this chris the
better and and then really
i i would be i don't think josh allen is
the type of guy that's going to hold
their feet to the fire too and make some
crazy demand of going
side eye you know sinai i know i know so
though
i don't feel that's the case with him
we'll see i mean of course i'm not
trying to get involved in his business
or anything like that but
hey this next prescott side eye this is
one where i think to what you're talking
about mike you get you get it going you
get it done
you know whether that comes june or
training camp or whatever
once they get this year's salary cap and
order the draft the free agency get
their team where they really want it
they can start to look into future years
and what's the money situation and all
those things
and you get josh allen signed up you do
i mean first off it's it's
he's one of the best players in football
he was in the mvp voting last year you
know it was
really the number three on that list
it's special
the year before that was damn good too
they went to the playoffs yeah it wasn't
superstar in 2019
but it was damn good every year it's
trended in the right direction to where
last year it took off
and yes if i'm them i'd be scared to let
the season play out
because if he has some year where it's
45 or 44 touchdowns and all that
yeah that asking price might go up
certainly so they might be able to get
them for the low come training camp
something like that
he is beloved in buffalo yes and there
are two ways to look at that
one you don't want to jeopardize it if
anything you want to strengthen the
relationship and if you
do take less than you could have gotten
elsewhere not elsewhere but you know
what i mean less than if you pushed it
all the way to the limit
like dak prescott did then you're a hero
also he's beloved there so he can do no
wrong hey josh wants to get paid let
josh get paid i don't know
how it would play out but this is where
the folks at caa
are gonna have a challenge in properly
managing josh allen's expectations yeah
protecting josh allen from himself
look todd france formerly of caa
is the one who did the dak prescott deal
which is the best
quarterback contract in nfl history in
my opinion
and todd france hasn't been hitting
singles and doubles the last two weeks
he's been hitting home runs
right he's the guy right now that the
general managers are talking about
as the as the agent he's the one
i'm not making any endorsements i'm just
telling you the people i know yeah
france is the guy right and he was at
caa and what happens
now caa is going to want to reclaim the
crown
and up next
josh allen with his second
contract and how much of that becomes a
factor chris
the these are all things to be
determined but we can't overlook
the reality that the agents are not
going to want to sign off on a deal that
isn't the absolute best deal that they
can
sell that hey look at what we got you
think todd france got a lot we got even
more
that's going to be part of this
discussion and conversation no
definitely an aspect that that's
you know a part of the conversation
you're right you're right but ultimately
you know it will go back on the josh
allen to go
wait am i really trying to get every
penny i can
or do i want to take a little less so we
can get a few players here there
whatever it may be
i think either way allen's sitting
pretty when you talk about like
lamar jackson baker mayfield josh allen
those guys that are going to be
uh in that conversation for
renegotiation
you know coming up in this year to me
josh allen is is the guy there and i
know that's
lamar's awesome i'm not trying to say it
but josh allen is a superstar
and the way he plays the game throws the
football
does all those things you know to me
he's he's the safest
bet of those three and if i'm buffalo
i'm trying to get that done before the
season starts
he's got rare special skills he takes
physical risk every time he steps out
onto a field
it's up to the team to manage the salary
cap my position was
is and always will be get
every penny get every
penny because those people who are
paying you those pennies and dollars and
thousands and millions they didn't get
to the point where they can write those
checks if their attitude wasn't
get every penny so it's
it's it's a fair way to enter into a
negotiation with a multi-billionaire
and we'll see how it all plays out
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit
subscribe for the latest news and
highlights from nbc sports